foreign
[Music]
yeah nice live together
I was his best man at his wedding oh
[__] he's my guy he gave him speech wow
it's good I was [__] up unbelievable
were you unbelievable I was like Bud
Lights yeah how many I have no idea
dude you didn't protect our Parks or
something yeah came in abstract I like
wet my pants
and I was like oh [__] I gotta give a
speech I was like I'll be all right I'm
used to giving speeches I got up there I
was like
uh
Matt's wife you're crazy Matt you're
[__] nuts this thing might be crazy
enough to work folks
got hit with an office party in Irvine
and a woman dude two women it was a
holiday party it was during Christmas
yeah a lady just sat like this because
you know how the tables are going that
way yeah yeah they didn't face me they
faced each other and just
[Laughter]
dude can I tell you that I I did I try
to do like the ultimate Road dog move
and invite a dude on stage with me to
backfire of course he backfired why'd
you do that he just yelled at me the
whole time I do want to go to uh Butcher
and watch them just you know [__] to me
whoa break down a cow yeah really yeah
cut it up you could do it [__] up dude
there's a butcher like right around the
corner yeah if you went in there like
can I watch they get the [__] it was
wave knives cheers
also it's a it's a Muslim butcher oh so
they're doing it uh yeah you defiled it
yeah you would defile the space Gentiles
can't even watch the animal in a certain
direction or something I think so they
do wild [__] yeah yeah they gotta kill
it a certain way yeah kosher and Halal
are cut the similar yeah that is funny
they're over there like bombing children
and then they're like wait hold on Cut
The Cow to the east yeah yeah how about
you guys get your priorities in order
you [__] dumbasses
yeah
my dad called my mom a dumbass
this is [__] last night really yeah
something about taking out the trash he
was like pal you have to take the trash
out he's like I'm doing it right now you
dumbass close to the garage door and I
was like Mom You're Gonna she's like
this is how he talks all the time I
gotta go and then he comes in like dead
what did you just call Mom I was like
Shane you're a little [__] you're like a
little [__] girl all I do is [__]
with him but I'm home I [__] them
start to finish dude I'm like damn it
what are you doing today he's like I
gotta do a couple things gotta sign the
book I'm like he's signing the book
again oh they're gonna go with the
[__] men's club again Dad he's like
what Shane shut up
and I'll be like well how are you
getting there he's like I'm driving well
how are you gonna get back then I just
forced him into admitting the drinks and
drives every day my mom used to lay on
the couch and I would just sit on her
when I was little that's like she'd
watch TV and I would just [__] sit on
my mom while she watched TV and I'll
just watching I laid on Phil watching
football
that's pretty sick too late like late
like I was big and I was a big [__]
kid I was huge dude I was laying on I
was like five eight
it was like two adult men playing on
each other watching football he was
probably buzzed as hell too he's
probably [__] up
the thing I remember most is just my
head would be on his stomach and it was
just constantly like
like even as a kid I was like that's
crazy something's wrong that's probably
horny now sick it's not good
to tone that down publicly horny what do
you mean he's probably horny they'll
like see a girl like like uh like
knee-high boots and he'll be like not
bad okay
you start hitting on waitresses yeah
yeah like totally it's and it's everyone
laughs right like my mom died and now my
dad's like oh yeah too bad you're
married huh Sam I'm like pointing to
like tens and I'm like yeah Dad that's
all this well that wasn't good
dude my dad God bless him he'll be like
yeah sorry buddy I can't come up and
watch the game uh I got I'm the head of
this grief group and I gotta do a
one-on-one with this lady her husband
died about 13 years ago and she's really
going through it and it's like Dad just
say you're going on a date yeah we're
happy for you you did your time with Mom
you rode hard for her please be getting
it in because I don't want you to become
like a model train guy or like a
birdhouse collector like what are you
talking about put a hooker with him
hey honey you can't be mad my Dad's here
I'm spotting my dad I'm having a freeway
with my dad dude
cat house you gotta kill yourself I know
yes I'm taking my son to get laid that's
the horniest dad of all time my dad's
where he doesn't know all the new tricks
honey so I'm here holding his hand
dude I would cut my penis off and yeah
dude you got your dad's ass
[Laughter]
the post not Clarity of a three-way with
your dad that's suicide dude yes
or you ascend and you're like nothing
does matter yeah true me my dad are like
Vikings yeah we're this is like an
ancient thing this is what men are
supposed to do it's like at the end of
it where they lock tongues we're
definitely not reaching the weirdest
level of gay there is
oh but that would probably be better at
it than me too I can't even imagine
seeing my dad's face receiving sexual
pleasure that would be so [__] weird
dude oh man you think he's your dad so
he definitely
he's doing down there
what the hell are you doing hey no horse
play yeah my boy's over there yeah God
damn it I'm about to come he's pissed
yeah how much of them call me do you
think of them getting up
yeah definitely that's a miniature face
[Laughter]
wink at you too because it's your dad he
would yeah he'd have some
[Laughter]
not bad shame let me tell you
not bad it runs in the family
Shake come here come here
get over here God damn it God damn it
what if your dad gave me like two
minutes and then you went for like a
half an hour
slow down jeez hey Shane save some for
the rest of us
glad you're watching your dad's
directions
how like they trick butterflies into
dedicating their whole life
for seven years this is this is the
moment dude this is I was wondering how
he would do you're doing I was wondering
I knew you're gonna do this he sent me
the longest [__] time like bummed out
that he's asking me to have you come
along and I was like yeah for sure
there's like eight texts that's what
kind of guy he is dude because you don't
know this [__] he knows me I
know we're friends but like it's still
like a hey you want me to bring another
guy it's kind of no yeah I know let's go
but I also knew I knew in my heart of
hearts Matt would rise to the occasion
and say things like have you ever heard
of super stimuli or whatever [__] I
have a non-popular take on Frank Sinatra
glorified karaoke singer that's I think
you gotta watch out you just
no this is what I've heard this opinion
before and I want to I want to
congratulate you for being on the
intelligence level of uh Big Jay
oakerson who's the other person that
expressed this to me that crooning was
easy and anybody could do it dude have
you ever been to an Italian wedding
every Italian dad croon's at their
daughter's wedding
to say goodbye they say they know the
baby the baby girls I will tell you this
she's gonna get plugged tonight so I
gotta sing it's like that take on that
take on if a guy picked up if a guy came
to my house to pick up one of my sisters
to go on a date I'm a crew I was young I
was six years younger but I was so croon
that's right
[Laughter]
there's always somebody around that is
prescribed yeah it's technical I would
say it's like Pentatonix it's crazy yeah
10 to 20 milligrams probably 10 to 20 to
sometimes you get you run into people
that are like 30 [__] 40 milligrams
crunch of time release Google December I
think porno I said he took it takes a
30. and I was like I didn't bring it up
I was like that's a lot some people
Munch the time release too they have
little balls and you can crack down on
them just get it all at once I've tried
to snort those things
[Applause]
plastic balls oh dude I I try to it's
crazy I tried drinking twice the one
time I was in college I tried to I was
on the Adderall I didn't realize even
like what it was I was drinking on it I
got all zoomed out and I was like at the
kind of a not like a super high level of
a concert and I was like I'm gonna jump
down to the next level
and I try to jump down and I got kicked
out of me
it was [__] up yeah I was like if I
could time it perfectly where all the
guards backs are turned I'll jump down
to the pit climb up and jump into like
the other area you're trying to get it
up to the stage they just snagged me
yeah of course I snagged me you're a
mess jump into the crowd I'll blend and
the crowd just parted as I jumped into
them the guy just beat the [__] I was
out of South Carolina South Carolina
knock my one shoe off I got back in with
one I kicked my other shoe off so I
didn't look suspicious so I walked in in
my socks and they thought my friend was
me and they started kicking him out and
I was like I just thought it happened I
was like [__] it my friend had to get
kicked out and then I got kicked out
again and then I snuck back in a third
time yeah No Lie by Tom Cruise this is
Mission Impossible I was on Admiral
that's why I cannot drink on Adderall I
snuck in I don't dude I snuck in with
the Aramark workers I just walked in
with them only in my socks and I climbed
up through under the bleachers and I
just emerged into like some seating
people like ah
you're gonna appreciate this sneaking at
a stadium I was gone it was an all-day
tailgate I was at South Carolina First
Tennessee SEC football it's a night game
in South Carolina and I'm standing there
and there's just a tiny fence between me
and the handicap section
and I literally I just stepped over it
no one no one better than I do I was
standing there just
I was all in the field I left my friends
they were in the student section face
walking around I was like
stepped in and dude people like looking
at me like checks out
fully checked out
yeah
[Laughter]
this guy he's by himself someone just
brought you a blanket and it thanks man
how [__] creepy is that it's like
[__] weird I called the place on the
way up here nice it wasn't the place I
did give him hell it wasn't the place or
they were like it's not us uh first of
all I was like dude I I was like I heard
you guys are like
doing like divisive political rhetoric
for one-year-olds and four-year-olds I'm
like can you explain to me why you would
do that and they're like that's very
interesting question that's a response
um it's not us it's the people we hire
to come do it here you might want to
talk to them blah blah and I'm like yeah
I hear that but I'm like you understand
that's weird like why would you want to
get into the minds of like pre-verbal
children I'm like that's so that's what
they create like early medieval Catholic
Church did I was like you want to tell
them that yes so I'm like I'm hitting
them I'm like you know that's that's
like when you want to like you have a
message that needs to get into very
little kids heads I'm like that's really
weird and Sinister [__] and I'm like you
guys should really not do that and
they're like well I mean we don't have
any control I'm like well you hired the
people so you're letting it in the
building and it's like
what's I was like they can't even
comprehend these ideas so why would you
be like trying to like someone's trying
to repeat them into their head as if
like to like indoctrinate like that's
[__] weird man it is like you imagine
if I ran a story thing for like
pro-trump things for like one-year-old
they would shut it down immediately I
was like that's right all the lesbians
that work there would run in and go I am
not a man
and I was like dude the message is a boy
he's got a penis it's like this girl
she's got a beginner
colored purple it's for girls purple's
[__] gay as [__] any boys like you
like the Vikings dude that's pretty sick
let's talk about the purple people
eaters good defense
you should do we should do just dude
[__] story time we have to today
we're reading the swimsuit edition by
Sports Illustrated
girls beat it yeah we don't trust you
won't tell your friends you guys can't
[__] read [__] anyway
yeah we got
we got dumb sex books for you guys
upstairs crime novels retards
you got booked to go to Florida no he
was like I was like I'll just come with
you know like hosts hey you were booked
a feature yeah we did a whole Southern
tour the whole Southern tour he brought
me I don't think anyone wanted me there
at all he brought me there I forgot to
underwear first I didn't pack underwrite
no undies the whole time that was the
feature and I was like I got a guy I'm
bringing that's great that's hilarious
the headliner stole his jokes yeah
headliner was a guitar guy and Shane
will grow up I was I was bombing
constantly and Shane would go up he was
doing well and the headliner started
just like he was bombing on a guitar
then he started doing callbacks to
Shane's [__] and then he started just
incorporating him into it was the
craziest act by the last couple shows he
was just stealing it was crazy but it
was when I was new so I was like that's
cool you know I was new enough to be
like at least you know he's saying that
was good true but that was dude it was
me and him and the headliner in a comedy
condo in South Carolina we just [__]
with this dude he sucks so far
supposed to look like Crystal yeah it
was like plastic like table stuff with a
lunch meat and this guy's just crushing
baloney being like guys I'm on the road
all the time I get [__] anytime like
okay dude he was like man if I was your
guy's age if I was single like you guys
I'd be getting [__] too I could go out
there and get [__] if I wanted but I'm
not gonna
he's standing eating lunch meat on a
tray in a club in South Carolina guitar
act yeah we're like a closet like a
Mexican bowling alley he's like dude I
could clean up out there dude you guys
have no idea we're like dude oh God I'm
pretty sure you're just crying when we
came in here
that was a fun [__] trip dude that
was so fun it was so funny me and him
were young and just bullying a headline
just fully like oh is that what you said
yeah it is Richie incognito's bully
reputation goes back to 2002. yeah bro
listen to this like so we're going here
dude who busted
yeah but this dude who was busting
wedges he ends up getting beaten up
getting beaten up by a jump by these
frat guys so they have this team meeting
uh you know [__] preaching like you
know this is a Band of Brothers like you
don't let nothing happen so rich
Incognito gets rigoni they don't really
know each other that well he goes hey
after practice like I'm gonna take you
you're gonna show me where this guy this
guy's house is after practice he gets
him in the pickup and driving or driving
down Greek Road or whatever and he's
like point out the Frat like which one
it was and we're going like points out
oh my God they park it Richie goes up
knocks door Revenue answer he [__]
kicks the door and then just starts it
starts beating him
dude dude
if you were up in your room and you were
there your brother's screaming I'd be
the dude I'd be the dude and Saving
Private Ryan just sitting in the
stairwell like no way I jump out of the
second floor
WTC I jump out of the second floor dude
that's literally a night they're like
this isn't real the big biggest dude on
Earth just broke into the house if you
did that right here
for himself
coach Bo's on that staff and when he
recalls that he remembers like kind of
the coaches talking about it and then
the next day when it's like the
headliner stuff's coming out about it
they're thinking like oh [__] we
shouldn't uh we shouldn't have got the
boys going yeah Rich he's got a team
meeting or somebody's got to do
something about this
holy [__] that is that is uh it's a true
nightmare
no dude come on
I got some [__] last night
straight to [__] the scariest thing
possible that would be a fun show Navy
Seals infiltrate frat houses and just
like how quick can Navy Seals take down
practice Yeah for one of your next
little sketches little
now
[Laughter]
yeah we hired uh Sean's a producer but
we hired Lamar we had fired lamare
traditionally yes I got fire was our
original producer uh because one time we
yeah he was original producer he was
just unbelievably badass yeah he just
[__] up constantly we had someone sat
out of frame for an entire time
he would eat on camera you'd hear him
[__] crackling he'd be high as [__]
all of a sudden you do a bag of chips
start to open
it was usually doing a loan where we had
nothing to say there's some chips so we
were both like [__] him it's his fault
so he fired him and by the way took the
firing like a champ like a [__]
Champion dude yeah he was just like oh
yeah right
you're talking like you got fired from
Microsoft fire from this who cares no I
know but I'm sure we're friends right so
it was weird before the Pod was big
right it was right when it was starting
I see the charts
I don't
I don't care for it
shut up over there this Show's always at
your mom's house
yeah I've gotten over a lot of that
where I'm like I know I'll at least get
60 people now which is just enough the
Cleveland and Pittsburgh ones are
[__] me up
see that song
like I think we think you can sell this
out again if we add another I'm like all
right do it try it yeah yeah worst comes
the worst you pack them all up front I'm
not doing that you scattered hurt my
feelings no I'll say you you sit where
the ticket you bought all right hire
ushers yeah higher ushers check his
ticket
I don't he doesn't look like he could be
up front riff Raffles yeah no no no no
that'd be funny if it was just like 100
people in the very upper level awesome
that would be actually pretty safe yeah
you could cheer them just be like losers
I'm not a loser for not selling this if
I bought a ticket I'd be right here
you're the ones who are losers
[Laughter]
in Cleveland what are you doing dude we
had a relationship
but yeah I'm not come on
oh bro if anything comes to me I want to
snag that thing if you snag it
I made contact but I didn't snack
it's dead right out of the [__] snag
it's that dude did you find the body
hold on give me the light I saw him go
down all right dude I smashed that thing
to Smithereens this is crazy you grabbed
that dude bro I'm at the top of my
[__] game right now
yeah there it is I see him I see him
it's official
zoom in Guardian
that's big
snag solemn and then throw him down and
stomped them I caught big I got him
twice hold on let me take a picture like
the guys who found Saddam
that joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]